the role of cheap and cheap prostheses
the former team could be similar
I've been out of google for months, which
is the first atp of the
daniel ferrer institution of the offices and
expiration of the party team is
populated by machines, that is, the
scientific and medical medical logos 702
magalháes jakarta 3 motion of the rates
of significance I am still
electronic earthquake and management
and accessible services that are in my club
for other successes then I heard quiroz lópez
gil and hector accepts without tact
they have done everything to me a thousand tortures and
violence
they have chained me  feet and hands have put me in
the sun for 15 days in a cell full
of mosquitoes and cold at dawn
risk of pneumonia my life is in serious
danger if they do not move I will die
these words were written in a letter
josé daniel ferrer who managed to outwit
his jailers  to send them to his
wife that words be heard today in the
European Parliament asking for
help from that man who has spent more than
a  After a decade suffering at the hands of
Castroism because of his
human rights activism, the case of Mr.
Ferrer is shocking, but like his
there are hundreds of other cases of
political prisoners of conscience and
thousands of well-documented pre-criminal prisoners
by the independent group
of  prisons serve to defend themselves torture
police violence against civil society
forced
patriations political persecution
arbitrary arrests and imprisonment of
activists, journalists and
human rights defenders are crimes on the order
of the day in that cuba committed by its
authorities
we must demand the immediate release
of julio daniel  ferrer and the many
others who suffer violations of their
human rights in accordance with the
political dialogue and cooperation agreement between
the european union and the
cuban government, an agreement that by the way
has not had a positive impact on
the civilian population play
we will also ask in addition to the resolution
we will ask  To the new high representative
who takes into account the position of this
parliament in its dialogues with the
Cuban authorities and requests
entry to our parliament in Cuba.
Accept this,
Quirós Tertsch sees everything
already in the reader and good morning,
thank you very much, President, today we are going to vote
here is a resolution on cuba on
josé daniel ferrer who is a
political prisoner one of the many
political prisoners in one of the
cruelest dictatorships in existence
today and yet it is a dictatorship
to which this parliament and especially the
union  The European Union and the commission are
really dealing with a treatment that it
does not deserve, as it was with the
dialogue and cooperation agreement that was signed
against all those voices that
said that they remembered that
concessions to a dictatorship that does not make
concessions that always declares that
they continue in what they have that they are going to
continue as a single party that they are going to
continue with the communist dictatorship and that
no one expects change  ios in this regard is
really a cooperation to reaffirm
that dictatorship that dictatorship that has
launched an expansionist adventure
throughout the continent that
is currently in venezuela has
one of the most monstrous dictatorships
also that has plunged the richest country
in Latin America into the  hunger in
desperation and in terror a
dictatorship that is destabilizing with
venezuela in the existing democracies
in the region in the face of
that I think I wait in this parliament
to vote on that resolution the fans of
ferrari for the freedom of cuba asefa
seen political scientist  left sánchez
sciamanna reader
yes thank you sir president
yes thank you sir president the
socialist group has shown in the negotiation
and now wants to reiterate its concern
about ferrer's case we demand his
immediate release because we understand
that his detention has been arbitrary and
the conditions of his prison are not  are
acceptable without any difference on
that side but yes  f we separate ourselves from the
instrumentalization of this unfortunate
human rights case, which is the
meaning of these urgencies, to
question how the resolution does
most of its content, the current
framework of relations, a European Cuba, the
agreement of something political is a
vindication of  the sterile 20 years
of isolation in which we would once
again align ourselves with the worst version of
American policy on Cuba, which
is sanctioning European companies that
are operating there the current framework with
its formalized dialogues on
human rights gives us more
influence  and of pressure and it is more useful in
general and for cases like this one from ferrer
the critical commitment with cuba is
our model thanks
ariston everything i want today spinetta
these pisces electrons in the reader
thanks president the right of the
extreme right still does not accept that
the infamous common position of mr.
aznar is over and they insist on acting as the
butler of mr.  tram and for that they
do not hesitate to present us with fantasies like the ones
we have just heard recently
here today they bring us a text in which he
instrumentalized in the arrest and the
judicial process with all the guarantees
of a criminal accused of kidnapping and
with a long history of crimes
Machoists including beatings of his ex-
wife who is 36 weeks pregnant in Cuba,
the opposition acts with total normality
where if she is persecuted, repressed,
detained and sometimes murdered in friendly countries such
as Colombia, Ecuador, Chile and
since the coup in Bolivia,
they will not find you images  of
the Cuban police repressing
opposition demonstrators as if
we see them daily in that
exemplary democracy' and
the accusations about
Cuba's alleged intervention in other
Latin American countries are simply ridiculous
the only intervention that Cuba makes in
other countries and not only in  latin america
are with teacher and doctor troops not
like the united state does in iraq syria  and
libya that seems to be of
little concern to the authors of this text
assume that cuba exists if the european union wins
in this respect and support a relationship
between equals with the cuban people
once they are simply fashionable this
wants
all the bones first and  I wanted hard anchor
bay high up
thank you president josé daniel ferrer
was arbitrarily detained and must be
released and even though this debate is
about the case of mr. ferrer the
dream is just one of the many examples
of serious human rights
violations that  continue to occur in
cuba mr. ferrer is one of hundreds of 27
political prisoners who are currently known to be
prisoners of a country that has
signed an agreement with the european union
that contains as a central element
regarding human rights and the
defense of democracy in  2017 this
chamber consented to the agreement with Cuba on
the condition that it will contribute to
improving human rights and living
conditions of all  two Cubans,
two years later, that condition is not
being met, it is time for the European Union to
speak out openly, Cuba
is not complying with the agreement, therefore,
we have no choice but to take
action without further delay within the framework
of the agreement, thank you,
Fernando, I am  and glutton or milito nor
eat this politician I don't kill nor that you
nomad your euro movie and eat this what
wei yanan to the reader you want from jobs
go in my opinion they go to pajín
warned capcet this half the picture is that
a type of order in the  federal the case
of natalia common esthetics cuba is
driven by exact estimates and her less than
minister sometimes or third guess
dialogues or positives they have gray
from everyone's house we have known how to make a
multitude of civilians ensured
democracy and we make our advice
daniela ferrera in  activity santiago de
cuba we return last game been opaque
bathroom the easiest to handle nor
terrorist would love to live will inject him
from cuba more than worry  pantes that serve
both parliament the project of
the democratic fabric that the
projecting cement and switzerland - project terrible
years said the project of the stage and the
art is in a 70 victories with respect to
the interior sales
robb that unites proto
the view of five tables with brussels
the Cubans who regimented me went to party
talking about the nation camps and production
sales efe latin artist
democratic socialist marathon so much later and
wanted sand and in act
arming sosa fortune
like love is an adjoining beach at the
level of the same cell and norm
relative international of the
josé daniel ferrer sisters have been 31 of wade
connected to the management of the situation
regarding access to san josé and
apple tablet names authorities that go to the
respective international and the best
famous is constant as the version
we have the freedom  of expression because
it hits her tico what motivates her the people
from manifestation associations
regarding international
in the declaration  tion
of operation
this
and you nomadic child and europe
today I want is nobody
thank you sir president and my respect
for you sir master guerín and in 2016 the
european union signed a treaty with cuba
that has respect for human rights as its essential and determining component
this parliament conditioned democracy
in its resolution of July 2017 by
approving a
suspension clause today cuba has more than 100
political prisoners and thousands of
arbitrary arrests josé daniel
ferrer is not a brutal anecdote it is a
category that shows that nothing has
changed in  cuba that continues to be the
totalitarian regime of the
castró dynasty and I want to remind you that the economy
in cuba is not the tourist palates
but the military political complex of
gaesa run by a former son-in-law of raúl
castro everything stays in the family the
european union cannot continue to close  our
eyes to reality if we prioritize
business ethics let's be consistent
let's eliminate articles that we don't  we will
comply let's recognize that our north
is in that couplet of the poet quevedo
powerful gentleman is a gift to
accept and this already has bad marks that are
democratic or what the reader wants
and
all I want is nicolao at hand
follow the reader
josé daniel ferrer was in force  maneiro
psc and nepalese period
patriotic students in the three curves of the
deterioration of the bread organ strips
until don is now without the leaf cuba or
that series meta little that the
maximum policy of the three are very
comfortable was with silo copy  save
me up hotels are going to create styles and the
parakeet copies in embargo
tropical exhibitors and for a week they searched for what
base and what to see institute nor for what
press via they destined me I am one in
phoenix ita andry that the thesis sanz and
kills or federer  ex to the cinema to the breasts
pérez otero antagonisms is epithelial
tonino mere politician in america 7
spreads x breasts it is for this jury
who panicked on the catalonia side my hi lived  ja
ni a ebro in os x epileptic copies
protests are already said activism
activision chalks the hypocritical letter and that
europe be demanded x in doses perica
tapats and trope in on de joe thug
handsome the honor and galio woman already lukewarm
apote lesmadrid own history and with
monopolies in three colors and
but although he let us see we were unprotected
from europe x 106 and believe me before it
is beautiful I did not feel in the austro
convenient
montalvo to have a mass for parties with a
drum to have a vision cut in the
south site towards the fia colleague in colindres
vote, blocking, promoting tancol,
promoting a minute
of the body, you see, what we do,
it would only come out of the bread, josé daniela
ferrera would
receive a copy of sillarejo,
proposals in the children to see the
portoviejo or benicio process, declares that
there was nothing for them, ravi shankar left me
minerals of  álex que bandes charged the
project very years from mama to brasses
payroll that we can open at 8 70 commented
principals calf by giovanni the
ski for  nothing with half so
for nothing the mother of the avoid these
politicians who were again Cubans that
I have received I feel great editorial
nothing or Cubans to talk about and they already
forgot help from bird and I think that velez of the
heart science sometimes to support  to
access and less time it seeks to publish
that type of probable occupants that
different and in the background main
emotions 15 until supporting the country or
copyist metal gear keeps us alive the
drumbeat provides them with the bread to ferrer
to the ideology that version and politics and
in a  copy
[Applause]
stones like the ix are colin balls
enough
is the leader
régine jane family of the state for the
payer insists the sporting champion
who writes after the vaccines program
in mind thanks to the training in
money and supply this tourism club and
in  networks is an expression worker in
off side of the moon in sad leaders of
the cers
spacey deductions for the
concession session is the rating of terol Ángel
valent  e these three days that's why it's my
freedom in cuba
schwarz conflict in the form of a cone
extensions avx at the head of the
standard event the session speak objectively even
though I have posted the sports slicks in
the space
coli' people add
the western brigade this solution
constitutes in  against the exercise of
numerous false acts and
grotesque considerations of life that
are created against these personify
without codifying the proposals for
interference in the internal affairs of Cuba
and indifference to the needs of the people
in a clear violation of
international law and the Charter of the
United Nations  saying of Cuban return and
more than one step but they can chaos of the
defenses that were possible to
normalize relations with
subjects of the dialogue and
understanding agreement between Cuba and Europe there
is no longer rectification of these borrowed its
members happen even the possibility of
suspension  since I remember the
operation of the
criminal elements  s ships that at 170 against Cuba
this aggravation you serious vices
and consequences
at the same time silence the defenses and
direct economic, social and cultural
were reached by the Cuban function
see how the policy of
international solidarity coincides nominally
in a health field despite the
blockade of the brigade
but in a treatment a minute
before
andrés
the magnificent country and its
meeting play wii outgoing people be
happy this monster play falls
josé daniel ferrer that violent conflict
weiss between the striker himself in the
end 7 6 and 7 the office raids
regarding champion fabrics and  webs
interventions in the support an electro
pop in bolivia in venezuela with the
manager in the medical care education
tweets the american network
simple interventions the front to the
rudeness word pension because they are
forming in craters comments
is cordial relationship there are three parts
motion the wall got
the  inclusion board my conversion  upson
terry porter seized in moguer in the
hands as bob peterson
josé daniel ferrer from the leader of the joni
in the patriotic union of cuba for this
position october summary in santiago de
cuba before 8:30 p.m. 617 visit from the
vendée through family reports the
report  highlights the expert with the case
alfa josé daniel ferrer schools have
notorious crises with the cube
bolt in arms and in havana more
present the one of the bird they lowered it
delegation the contact in the triton this
is it to the cuban ministry they went to
first show it is understood sixth  november
the day after hour intervention his
family include street celdrán 'stable' i
had that time the administration of
clearone reaping world with the
treatment in this regard curvatures
pacts works editions fundamentals
freedom and human dignity include the
right to offer trail indices will never
endorsed places
when  the master ferrer still
duly states in the
way money at level and character are going to  aguar
engagement red cuba on human rights and
software in frank williams is not bush
behind waste to the classroom of the center of nec
mind
the president of the stanford
indert I entered the gamecube to wii if there is one of
the drums in the berklee the
central data of the wef opens  in the face
inauguration suite management demand curve
of full support of all
the stage no one exclusive no greater
orientation policy of doubly
place example of water political
deadlock
operation agreement be simple or its
application in raid is now in the center
part  led for example of critical water
long island with the cuban leadership
the resources of opportunity the 30 new
cooperation for use or pediatricians
cement water within the saint about
in this way the dialogue and blom street
cuba have stopped world
wrestling commented on human rights micos regarding
it was the foundation of the freedom and fall
city arts center for us analyzing
what are those of can only be with the
fool res  regarding the annual expansion of
data economic development who have
seen this new a critical intruder link
elements suddenly white cube we can
the country company in x
modernization then one of the girls
of our agreements company in the country
this political reform in economic
model  green net economy love solution
of zions missing young bell of
contributing every one android seyfried
ems andes in raids
in khyber max